welcome to this video playing the Trojan
trillion night from the Netherlands hmm
this one yeah always think that if or
shouldn't be should be ok but I had this
recently against the sky I think with
this he played with the capture on d4
and g65 Knight f3 utopia and g6 I
remember and I still don't know it would
know how it is played ok I'm going to
prevent this for a moment b5 that try
for this Queen edge for tecnica I'm
always always going for this crew the
text let's let's try that if I play you
for everybody should should play it like
em play it like mp4 very often should be
plating directly maybe this is just bad
i'm not claiming that this is this is
fantastic um okay this is interesting
though should i take RT five orbit i
also have a bishop f form but ok let's
let's take here first
okay so Bishop to g5 maybe with the idea
to capture you know this is this is okay
i'm pretty sure d 5 of this defiant is
probably not the refutation of my my
setup here it looks some quite dangerous
i mean white has basically all pieces in
play well black still has bishop on c
aid and it's not very well coordinated
yeah and short-term i'm just threatening
FG six and the the whole bunch of
captures on f6 came prevented night to
be five FML then is got this check
Bishop f4 this 95 m not a multi grade a
DM
okay i play this lazy move it's not so
clear to me what is next movers they
cannot really move one of the nights
especially not the design right and if
you cannot move this it's difficult to
get stuff developed yeah okay and now
maybe I should I capture I wonder if I
should take I'm not clear to me okay
let's take him and maybe now just yeah
just pile up on that file i'm brooke f3
and we'll get one let's also look h3
maybe ok so we trying to free himself a
bit
once the night only for so that i can
quickly come to f6 also look h3 of
course exam is in the mix group age
three he can take you for okay and
knight Knight f6 is not necessarily
decisive takes takes rook takes at the
end on f6 and he can take me to whom
maybe route III intending Knight f6 come
on come on keep it simple this is a
threatening rookie three with the win
and what exactly is a smooth now okay
just just keep this protected I'm
threatening look III and maybe just
coming with rook f1 hook h3y ah ok maybe
not the best move but it keeps things
together and I don't really see what
he's doing now look III years also in
yeah okay I think this was a good
practical move at least I probably had
something better but I I didn't really
seem
it's very difficult for him to find a
move-in as rookie three as such a
substantial threat it wins the Queen
basically yeah again rupee three I only
want to ever have something better and
now come on win the material
this is an additional problem that 97
would pick up more material check
I Wondrich the eight getting getting
stuff traded so what is this action I
only of course I'm material lab but how
much what is it actually this is Queen
against to Bishop son hmm okay the the
winning idea is to to gain to to to to
get get the pawns here this is strong v
5 mm that's not easy actually this is
not kind morning I should have I should
have considered this b5 hmm not good
my idea is to play a five maybe keep the
pawn
very tricky it should be it should be
I'd really but it's not not easy at all
check green juice have made checkmate ed
was it was not defendable anymore it
there was a scam moment here really when
all the porns get traded here on the on
the queenside i don't really know if i
can win i don't think so ok click your
bet go back around here yeah f5 is a
very committed decision it gives up a
five but it is dangerous at least in a
practical game it's very dangerous to
play but this i don't know i mean really
looks looks tricky okay all the computer
is very skeptical Bishop g5 with plus
1.4 or something yeah okay but this here
it wants to play 95 with the defense
cell phone with the defense not quite
sure why and how but this is this is
almost winning according to the machine
right h7 as a defense now interesting
brooke d one seems to be better but here
here why this is winning rookie oneness
stronger ok but ok this is also plus 2.5
and it keeps control over things check
yeah there was this scam moment though I
hadn't seen hadn't seen be five at all
95a soraya no fear
it's probably the check of the move that
shields down the win yeah he has no
gakuen g7 s is too much you can play
this but then jag least I can pick up
the bishop if everything else fails oh
ok thanks for watching